Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook.
Today we are in Psalm 86:11. All right,
we're reading David's words in Psalm 86:11, where he says,
"Teach me your way, Lord, that I may rely on your faithfulness.
Give me an undivided heart that I may
fear your name." Now the same word is used in 1
Chronicles 12:38, where it said, "All these men who
were fighting men volunteered to serve in the ranks.
They came to Hebron fully determined to make David king over
all Israel. And all the rest of the Israelites were also
of echad, they were of one mind to make
David king." So that's what it means,
undivided, united, whole. Now, in this
passage, I want you to notice four things.
I want you to notice that number one, David saw something in himself by the
insight the Holy Spirit gave him. You see that?
He saw, he realized that his heart was divided.
Now this picture of the heart is consistent with the rest of scripture.
When we are unsaved, we are people of one nature,
not able to do anything but evil. But when we are saved, we're raised to
new life in Christ, we have the Holy Spirit living within us, and we become
people of coexisting natures, a regenerated
nature of spiritual life, a nature of sin that will
unfailingly lead us towards sin and death.
And when our heart is divided, it prevents us from consistently
living in the fear of the Lord. That's what David says here.
And that matters because Proverbs teaches us that by
the fear of the Lord, men depart from evil. Right?
So it's going to be hard to depart from evil as long as you don't have the fear of
the Lord, and it's hard to have the fear of the Lord if you
have a divided heart. Now I want you to notice that
before you are saved, you don't have a divided heart.
It is united in the wrong direction.
But once you know the Lord, you have a heart that is divided.
Now, I hope in the last few days the Lord has helped you to see this like
he did David. All right? Number two,
David was drawn by the Holy Spirit to pray this division
would be healed by God's power. I just want to point out this wasn't David
being overly dramatic or asking for something that wasn't
the Lord's will. This is the Holy Spirit. This is scripture.
The Holy Spirit inspired David to ask
this.
He's the one who put these words in David's mouth.
Again, possibility glasses, right?
If the Holy Spirit inspired David to ask this,
wouldn't he also do the same for you?
Wouldn't he inspire you to ask that your heart also
would be undivided?
David was implicitly trusting God.
Number three, David was implicitly trusting God to do what he asked.
And number four, David knew this united heart would
produce a heart and behavioral change.
It would make him fear the Lord more consistently.
Now,
here's the question. As a believer, can you do any less than
David did? And is God any less willing to do
it now than he was back then?
So today's metaphor is from a divided heart to a
united heart, leading to a changed attitude of fear of the Lord and
power to live in victory. That's holiness.
So as we seek the Lord, the first thing I want to tell you is that we
talked about loving God with all of your heart yesterday.
And now we're talking about
that David's saying, "I want the Lord to unite my heart,"
because he recognizes the division in his heart.
And if that's the case, then if you've seen the same thing, how does
God heal it? Yesterday we were going to start talking about how God does
this. How does he go about it? Well, the metaphor here is that
God says you've got a divided heart.
I can't help you love the Lord your God with all your heart as long as your
heart is divided. You're going to need to ask him to unite your heart.
You're going to need to pray and begin seeking the Lord and saying, "Lord, I want
my heart to be undivided. I want it to be one
so that I can adequately fear your name."
So let's look at tomorrow. We will be continuing on. All right?
And I just want to encourage you, don't give up. Don't quit. Start asking.
Today's the day. Start asking. Start seeking.
"Lord, I want that division healed." Maybe you used to think it wasn't possible.
Maybe you used to think this is something I just have to live with till I get to
heaven.
But I'm telling you
that the Bible's saying something different.
That when the Holy Spirit inspired and put these words into David's
heart, he was showing him what he could do, not
something he had to live with and someday he was going to give him an undivided
heart when he got to heaven. But I believe that the Holy Spirit is able to give you
an undivided heart now by the power of grace. All right?
So we'll keep talking about tomorrow. For right now, let's do our workbook.
Let's meditate on things, and I'll see you tomorrow.